Is it me or do you have a good ear? Maybe it's just an impression, but the song likes to relax the sound of people who talk to you about super captivating topics for hours. It sounds good, because I have something really interesting for you. The first mobility service by subscription to the country offered by the mobile audience. Yes, of course. At Star, you can subscribe to your 5G forfeiture without being attached. Mobile audience.
是我的错觉，还是你的耳朵真的很灵？也许这只是个错觉，但这首歌喜欢舒缓那些跟你聊超级迷人话题数小时的人的声音。这听起来不错，因为我有些非常有趣的事要告诉你。全国首个由移动观众提供的按需订阅移动服务。是的，当然。在Star，你可以订阅你的5G套餐而不受绑定。移动观众。
To you, the difference. Or on our website. Good evening, as his husband of 18 years, James, was rusted on to work a night shift over the weekend. Hours earlier, James had phoned Craig to remind him to start packing for their upcoming trip to Chicago in celebration of Craig's 48th birthday in five days time. Their call ended with the men telling one another, I love you. Craig's Orange Chevy Avalanche was parked in a lot off the Metro Inn, a budget hotel in his home city of Jackson, Mississippi. Located near the intersection of Highway 80 in the city's west, the lot was relatively small with around two dozen angled parking spots split into two near-even rows. A Wendy's fast food restaurant was located on its northern border, with winding on and off ramps for the Interstate 20 highway to the south.
为你，与众不同。或者访问我们的网站。晚上好，因为他的丈夫18岁的詹姆斯周末被安排值夜班。几小时前，詹姆斯曾打电话给克雷格，提醒他开始收拾行李，准备他们即将前往芝加哥的旅行，以庆祝五天后克雷格48岁的生日。他们的通话以两人互道“我爱你”结束。克雷格的橙色雪佛兰雪崩皮卡停在密西西比州杰克逊市家乡的一家经济型酒店——地铁客栈外的停车场里。该停车场位于该市西部的80号公路交叉口附近，面积相对较小，大约有两打斜向停车位，分为两排，几乎对等。停车场北面是一家温迪快餐店，南面则是80号州际公路盘旋的出入口匝道。
The lot was partially framed with small tree-lined nature strips and could be accessed to the east via Frontage Road and to the west from the busy thoroughfare of Ellis Avenue. Shortly after 4.45am, as Craig assessed his options, a white Jeep Cherokee SUV carrying four occupants entered the parking lot. Two young Caucasian men got out of the vehicle and approached Craig, who explained his dilemma. He asked the pair if they had a coat hanger he could use to try and jimmy the lock in his car door. The men moved back and forth between their Jeep and Craig's car, engaging Craig in conversation while seemingly looking for an item that could be of assistance. 15 minutes later, a dark green Ford F-250 pickup truck carrying three occupants drove into the car park before leaving via the Ellis Avenue exit. The two men who were helping Craig got back into their Jeep and followed the Ford. Moments later, both vehicles returned and stopped in close vicinity to where Craig was waiting by his car.
停车场部分由绿树成荫的小型自然地带环绕，东面可通过前沿路进入，西面可通过繁忙的埃利斯大道进入。凌晨4点45分刚过，正当克雷格评估他的选择时，一辆载有四人的白色吉普切诺基SUV驶入停车场。两名年轻的白人男子从车里出来，走向克雷格，克雷格向他们解释了自己的困境。他问这两人是否有衣架，可以用来试着撬开他车门的锁。两人在他们的吉普车和克雷格的车之间来回走动，与克雷格交谈，同时似乎在寻找能帮上忙的物品。15分钟后，一辆载有三人、深绿色的福特F-250皮卡驶入停车场，随后从埃利斯大道出口离开。帮过克雷格的两名男子回到他们的吉普车里，并跟上了那辆福特车。片刻之后，两辆车都返回并停在克雷格在车旁等候的附近。
The two men who had assisted Craig earlier emerged from the Jeep and were joined by the driver of the Ford, a young, white, blonde-haired, blue-eyed male. He called Craig a racist slur and yelled, Get away from my truck. Suddenly, one of the men from the Jeep punched Craig in the face, knocking him to the ground. The driver of the Ford then straddled Craig and proceeded to hit him repeatedly around the head while cussing and shouting racial abuse. The remaining passengers of the group's two vehicles watched on as the assailant spent the next three and a half minutes beating Craig. Afterwards, he stole Craig's mobile phone, wallet, and wedding ring before jumping back into the driver's seat of the Ford. As the Jeep drove away, one of its passengers yelled out, White Power. In response, the driver of the Ford raised his fist in the air and yelled back, White Power.
先前帮助过克雷格的两名男子从吉普车里出来，福特的司机也加入了他们，那是一个年轻的白人，金发蓝眼。他用种族歧视的污言秽语辱骂克雷格，并大喊：“离我的卡车远点。”突然，吉普车上的一名男子打了克雷格的脸，把他打倒在地。接着，福特的司机骑在克雷格身上，一边咒骂和高喊种族侮辱，一边对他的头部进行连续殴打。这两辆车的其余乘客在一旁看着行凶者对克雷格进行了长达三分半钟的殴打。之后，他抢走了克雷格的手机、钱包和结婚戒指，然后跳回福特的驾驶座。当吉普车开走时，其中一名乘客大喊：“白人力量！”作为回应，福特的司机将拳头高举在空中，回喊道：“白人力量！”
As the Ford pulled out of the parking lot, its headlights illuminated Craig, stumbling along the edge of Ellis Avenue, just to the right of the exit. The driver steered towards him, mounted the curb, and ran him over. The Ford's occupants yelled more racial abuse out of the window as the vehicle sped away. The state of Mississippi is located in America's Deep South, bordered by Louisiana, Alabama, and Arkansas. During the 1800s, black slaves were used to tend to the farming land that was owned by Mississippi's white citizens, and by 1860, these slaves accounted for 55% of the state's population. The state was so heavily invested in slavery that race became a dominant theme of Mississippi's politics. On January 9, 1861, Mississippi declared secession from the U.S. Union and became one of America's original Confederate states. In the declaration, slavery was referred to as, quote, the greatest material interest of the world.
当福特驶离停车场时，它的车灯照亮了正在埃利斯大道边缘踉跄前行的克雷格，就在出口的右侧。司机朝他开去，冲上马路牙子，把他撞倒在地。当车辆加速驶离时，福特车上的乘客摇下车窗大声叫嚷着更多的种族侮辱。密西西比州位于美国深南部，与路易斯安那州、阿拉巴马州和阿肯色州接壤。在19世纪，黑奴被用来照料密西西比州白人公民拥有的农田，到1860年，这些奴隶占该州人口的55%。该州对奴隶制的投入如此巨大，以至于种族成为了密西西比州政治的主导主题。1861年1月9日，密西西比州宣布脱离美利坚合众国，成为美国最初的邦联州之一。在宣言中，奴隶制被称为“世界上最大物质利益”。
In April that same year, the ongoing controversy between the southern and northern states over the enslavement of black people gave rise to the American Civil War. Over 80,000 Mississippians fought in the war, many of whom were motivated by fear of losing white supremacy. During this time, the majority of Mississippi's black population were enslaved and living on plantations. Many had been forced there by ship or over land via the domestic slave trade. In 1865, when the Confederacy was defeated and the Civil War ended, slavery was abolished by the 13th Amendment to the United States Constitution, with Mississippi being one of the few states that voted against the amendment. Five years later, Mississippi rejoined the U.S. Union, but the state continued to face intense interracial conflict and was center stage during the Civil Rights Movement of the mid-20th century. This was most evident in the state's capital city, Jackson. Known as the city with soul, Jackson is renowned for its music, architecture, museums, historic cultural districts, performing arts, and a vibrant nightlife. However, like the rest of Mississippi, the city has a dark and complex history when it comes to racial inequality.
同年4月，南方州和北方州之间关于黑奴制的持续争议引发了美国内战。超过8万名密西西比人参加了这场战争，其中许多人是出于对失去白人至上地位的恐惧。在此期间，密西西比州绝大多数黑人人口都被沦为奴隶，生活在种植园里。许多人是通过船只或陆路经由国内奴隶贸易被迫来到那里的。1865年，当邦联战败、内战结束时，美国宪法第十三修正案废除了奴隶制，而密西西比州是少数几个投票反对该修正案的州之一。五年后，密西西比州重新加入美利坚合众国，但该州继续面临激烈的种族间冲突，并成为20年中期民权运动的中心舞台。这一点在州首府杰克逊最为明显。杰克逊被称为“灵魂之城”，以其音乐、建筑、博物馆、历史文化区、表演艺术和充满活力的夜生活而闻名。然而，像密西西比州的其他地方一样，这座城市在涉及种族不平等时有着黑暗而复杂的历史。
Between 1877 and 1950, 22 people were lynched in Jackson's Hines County, more than anywhere else in the state. In 1954, the federal governments forced end to segregation resulted in Jackson becoming more racially diverse. This prompted many white people to move away from the city, rendering some neighborhoods of Jackson almost exclusively black. One of the most infamous hate crimes that occurred in Mississippi was the 1955 murder of 14-year-old Emmett Till, a black teenager who allegedly woof-whistled at a white woman. In retaliation for this perceived slight, two white men kidnapped and killed Emmett before dumping his body into the Tallahatchie River. An all-white jury acquitted the men, even though they later admitted to the murder. Another race-fuelled incident occurred in 1964, when two 19-year-old black men, Charles Moore and Henry D., were murdered by members of the white supremacist hate group, the Ku Klux Klan, in the Mississippi town of Roxy.
在1877年至1950年间，杰克逊所在的海因斯县有22人被私刑处死，比该州其他任何地方都多。1954年，联邦政府强行结束种族隔离，导致杰克逊的种族变得更加多元化。这促使许多白人搬离该市，使得杰克逊的一些社区几乎全都是黑人。密西西比州发生的最臭名昭著的仇恨犯罪之一是1955年14岁埃米特·蒂尔的谋杀案，他是一名黑人少年，据称曾对一名白人女性吹口哨。为了报复这种被认为的轻蔑，两名白人男子绑架并杀害了埃米特，然后将他的尸体扔进了塔拉哈奇河。一个全白人的陪审团判处这些人无罪，尽管他们后来承认了谋杀。另一起由种族引发的事件发生在1964年，当时两名19岁的黑人男子查尔斯·摩尔和亨利·D，在密西西比州的罗克西镇被白人至上主义仇恨团体三K党的成员谋杀。
Charles and Henry were tied to a tree, beaten, and then dumped in the Mississippi River to drown. That same year, a gang of Ku Klux Klansmen that included several police officers abducted and murdered one black man, James Cheney, and two white Jewish men, Andrew Goodman and Michael Schwerner, in Neshoba County, because they were trying to help black people register to vote. During the 1960s, several serious crimes were committed against civil rights activists by white supremacists, and racist aggression was constant. In 1963, civil rights activist Medgar Evers was shot outside his home by a member of the Ku Klux Klan, which caused a national outrage and was pivotal to the passing of the Civil Rights Act the following year. From 1980 to 1990, Jackson's white population dropped to 43%, and by 2000, white people accounted for just over a quarter of the city's population. Although that number showed a slight increase by 2011, racially motivated crimes committed by white people against the city's black citizens remained prevalent.
查尔斯和亨利被绑在树上殴打，然后被扔进密西西比河淹死。同年，一个包含数名警察的三K党团伙在内肖巴县绑架并谋杀了一名黑人男子詹姆斯·切尼以及两名白人犹太男子安德鲁·古德曼和迈克尔·施韦纳，因为他们试图帮助黑人登记投票。在20世纪60年代，白人至上主义者针对民权活动家犯下了多起严重罪行，种族侵犯不断发生。1963年，民权活动家梅德加·埃维尔斯在家门外被三K党成员枪杀，这在全国引起了愤怒，并对第二年《民权法案》的通过起到了关键作用。从1980年到1990年，杰克逊的白人人口下降到43%，到2000年，白人仅占该市人口的四分之一多一点。尽管这一数字在2011年略有上升，但白人对该市黑人公民实施的种族动机犯罪仍然普遍存在。
Craig Anderson had lived in Jackson, Mississippi for most of his adult life. He was originally from Holmes County and was primarily raised by his mother after his father died. Craig was one of four children with an older sister and two younger brothers. He grew up to become a kind and courteous person who was particularly caring towards children and the elderly. His defining feature was what his sister Barbara called his grand piano smile. As a young man, Craig moved 70 miles south to Jackson, where in 1993, at the age of 30, he was introduced to James, another African-American man. James later told journalist Albert Samaha from BuzzFeed News that by the end of their first day, the pair had fallen for one another. The cautious and organized the James kept Craig in check, while Craig's warm and easygoing personality allowed James to loosen up a little.
克雷格·安德森在密西西比州杰克逊市度过了他成年后的大部分时光。他原籍霍姆斯县，父亲去世后主要由母亲抚养长大。克雷格是四个孩子中的一个，有一个姐姐和两个弟弟。他长大后成为一个善良、有礼貌的人，尤其关心儿童和老人。他最显著的特征是他姐姐芭芭拉所说的“三角钢琴般的微笑”。年轻时，克雷格向南搬了70英里来到杰克逊，1993年，30岁的他在那里经人介绍认识了另一名非裔美国人詹姆斯。詹姆斯后来对《BuzzFeed新闻》的记者阿尔伯特·萨马哈说，在他们相识的第一天结束时，两人就已经坠入爱河。谨慎而有条理的詹姆斯管束着克雷格，而克雷格温暖随和的性格让詹姆斯得以放松一些。
On a number of occasions, James surprised Craig with trips to cities like Chicago, New Orleans, and Miami. There, the couple were more comfortable being affectionate in public, unlike in Jackson, where members of the LGBTQI community often faced discrimination. Five years into their relationship, James and Craig bought a house in Jackson. James wasn't initially keen on the property as he thought it was ugly, but Craig saw its potential and spent the next few years turning it into a home. He put in new flooring, painted the walls, renovated the kitchen, and planted a garden full of flowers. Craig also picked out all of the furniture and decorated the house with plush green carpet and paintings of tigers. The couple were active churchgoers at the first Hyde Park Missionary Baptist Church, where Craig sang as tenor in the choir. By 2004, Craig and James had been together for 11 years and knew they wanted to spend the rest of their lives together.
在多次场合中，詹姆斯用去芝加哥、新奥尔良和迈阿密等城市的旅行给克雷格带来惊喜。在那里，这对情侣更习惯在公共场合表现出亲密感，而不像在杰克逊，LGBTQI社群的成员经常面临歧视。交往五年后，詹姆斯和克雷格在杰克逊买了一栋房子。詹姆斯起初并不喜欢这处房产，因为他觉得它很丑，但克雷格看到了它的潜力，并在接下来的几年里把它变成了一个家。他铺设了新地板，粉刷了墙壁，翻新了厨房，并种满了鲜花。克雷格还挑选了所有的家具，用毛绒绿地毯和老虎画装点房子。这对夫妇是海德公园第一传教士浸信会教堂的积极礼拜者，克雷格在唱诗班里担任男高音。到2004年，克雷格和詹姆斯已经在一起11年了，他们知道自己想要共度余生。
At the time, Mississippi didn't recognize same-sex marriage, so they held a private ceremony in New Orleans, where they exchanged vows and rings. Months later, Craig was offered a job as a production technician at a Nissan vehicle manufacturing plant in Canton, roughly 20 miles north of Jackson. Craig was thrilled as the position was higher paid than his previous job, and James later told BuzzFeed News that he'd reacted by, quote, jumping around, smiling like it was the best day of his life. The couple celebrated with a trip to Memphis, Tennessee. In 2007, a situation arose within James' extended family that resulted in a relative needing to re-home their newborn baby boy. James was eager to adopt, but Craig wasn't sure they were ready for the responsibility. They decided to proceed with the adoption, and Craig immediately embraced the role of a devoted father. He loved spoiling their adopted son with chocolates and toys.
当时，密西西比州不承认同性婚姻，因此他们在纽奥良举行了一场私人仪式，在那里他们交换了誓言和戒指。几个月后，克雷格获得了一份工作，担任位于杰克逊以北约20英里坎顿的日产汽车制造厂的生产技术员。克雷格欣喜若狂，因为这个职位的薪水比他以前的工作要高，詹姆斯后来告诉《BuzzFeed新闻》，他的反应是“跳来跳去，笑得就像那是他生命中最美好的一天”。这对夫妇去田纳西州孟菲斯旅行来庆祝。2007年，詹姆斯的大家庭中出现了一种情况，导致一位亲戚需要为他们刚出生的男婴重新安置家庭。詹姆斯渴望收养，但克雷格不确定他们是否准备好承担这个责任。他们决定继续进行收养，克雷格立即扮演了一个慈爱父亲的角色。他喜欢用巧克力和玩具宠爱他们的养子。
James later stated, Those were the years when we were like, this is it, we're going to like our life. We both got good jobs, we were living real comfortable, we had everything we wanted. We go to church, we go to work, we pay our taxes and come home to our family. That's all you can ask for. In the early hours of Sunday, June 26, 2011, 911 received a call from a woman at Jackson's Metro Inn just off Highway 80. She had just witnessed a dark green Ford pickup truck run over a black man in the motel's parking lot. The perpetrators, who were identified as being young and white, were also heard hurling racial abuse at the victim.
詹姆斯后来表示：“那几年我们觉得，就是这样了，我们要喜欢我们的生活了。我们都有好工作，我们过得很舒服，我们拥有所需的一切。我们去教堂，去工作，我们纳税，然后回到家陪伴家人。这就是你所能奢求的一切。”2011年6月26日星期日凌晨，911接到了一名来自杰克逊80号公路旁地铁客栈的一名女性的电话。她刚刚目睹了一辆深绿色的福特皮卡在汽车旅馆的停车场撞倒了一名黑人男子。行凶者被确认是年轻的白人，人们还听到他们对受害者大声进行种族侮辱。
When police arrived at the Metro Inn, they found several irate people gathered around a severely injured and unresponsive Craig Anderson on the curb of Ellis Avenue just outside the car park. Craig was rushed to hospital, but his injuries were severe and the situation dire. His attackers were divided between two vehicles, the Ford used in the hit and run, and a white Jeep SUV. Both cars were witnessed driving past the lot immediately after the attack, while their passengers pointed and laughed. Police sped onto the Interstate 20 where the Ford was last sighted travelling east and caught up to the vehicle. As they pulled up beside it, one officer locked eyes with the driver, a young white man with blonde hair and blue eyes. The officer noted, he had this blank stare about him. It was chilling, like a cold-hearted look. I'll never forget that look.
当警察到达地铁客栈时，他们发现几名愤怒的人聚集在停车场外埃利斯大道马路牙子上一个受重伤且无反应的克雷格·安德森周围。克雷格被紧急送往医院，但他的伤势严重，情况危急。他的袭击者分散在两辆车里，一辆是肇事逃逸时使用的福特汽车，另一辆是白色的吉普SUV。据目击者称，袭击发生后，两辆车都立即开过停车场，车上的乘客一边指指点点一边大笑。警察加速驶上80号州际公路，福特车最后被目击向东行驶，并追上了这辆车。当他们将车停在它旁边时，一名警官与司机——一个金发蓝眼的年轻白人男子——四目相对。这名警官注意到：“他有一种茫然的凝视。这让人毛骨悚然，就像一种冷酷无情的眼神。我永远不会忘记那个眼神。”
The driver was ordered to pull over and provide his driver's license, which identified him as 19-year-old Daryl Deadman. There were two female passengers in his truck, 17-year-old Shelby Richards and 18-year-old Sarah Graves. All three teens acted like they had no idea why the police had pulled them over, with the Deadman's demeanour akin to someone on their way home after an uneventful day. Shelby Richards seemed to think the whole law deal was a joke, while Sarah Graves appeared uncomfortable, as though she was part of something she didn't want to be involved with. The police inspected the Ford's exterior and found blood and brain matter on the right side of the front bumper. Later that morning, James returned to the home he shared with Craig Anderson after finishing his graveyard shift at the Airplane Parts factory where he worked. He quickly discovered that his husband wasn't home, and the next thing he knew, police officers were knocking at the door. They revealed that Craig had been in an accident overnight, and when James asked to go see him, the officers informed him that it wouldn't be possible, as Craig had been killed.
司机被命令靠边停车并出示驾照，驾照显示他是19岁的达里尔·迪德曼。他的卡车里有两名女乘客，17岁的谢尔比·理查兹和18岁的萨拉·格雷夫斯。这三个青少年表现得好像完全不知道警察为什么要拦下他们，迪德曼的举止类似于某人在经历了一个平淡无奇的日子后在回家的路上。谢尔比·理查兹似乎认为整个执法过程是个笑话，而萨拉·格雷夫斯则显得很不自在，好像她是她不想参与的事情的一部分。警察检查了福特车的外观，在右侧前保险杠上发现了血迹和脑浆。那天早上晚些时候，詹姆斯在飞机零件厂上完夜班后，回到了他和克雷格·安德森共同的家。他很快发现他的丈夫不在家，接下来他所知道的就是警察在敲门。他们透露克雷格昨夜出了事故，当詹姆斯要求去见他时，警官告诉他那是不可能的，因为克雷格已经遇害了。
Daryl Deadman, Shelby Richards and Sarah Graves were taken into custody and interviewed separately. Deadman told police that Craig Anderson had jumped in front of his truck, while Richards, who was Deadman's girlfriend, laughed when she was brought into the interview room. In contrast, Sarah Graves appeared in shock and was crying. Once she had settled, she detailed the lead-up to the incident. On the night of Saturday, June 25, Graves and several dozen other youths were celebrating a birthday in a field near the village of Puckett, around 30 miles southeast of Jackson. They engaged in underage drinking around a bonfire until the party reached its conclusion at 4.15am. Ten party-goers then made a plan to meet up at a gas station in Brandon, a predominantly white neighborhood on the outskirts of Jackson, where the majority of the youths lived. At the gas station, the group discussed going to Jackson, which was a short drive west.
达里尔·迪德曼、谢尔比·理查兹和萨拉·格雷夫斯被拘留并分别接受了讯问。迪德曼告诉警察，克雷格·安德森跳到了他的卡车前面，而作为迪德曼女友的理查兹被带进审讯室时笑了。相比之下，萨拉·格雷夫斯显得惊恐万状并在哭泣。平静下来后，她详细讲述了事件的导火索。6月25日星期六晚上，格雷夫斯和其他几十名年轻人正在杰克逊东南约30英里、普克特村附近的一个田野里庆祝生日。他们在篝火旁饮酒，直到派对在凌晨4点15分结束。随后，十名派对参与者计划在布兰登的一家加油站会合，布兰登是杰克逊郊区的一个主要由白人居住的社区，大多数年轻人住在那里。在加油站，这群人讨论去杰克逊，那里向西只需短途车程。
Three party-goers called at a night and went home, while the remaining seven committed to the trip. 23-year-old William Montgomery drove 18-year-olds John Rice and John Blalak and 20-year-old Dylan Butler in his white Jeep Cherokee SUV. Daryl Deadman took Sarah Graves and Shelby Richards in his green Ford F-250 pickup truck. During the drive into Jackson, Deadman and the girls received a call from the Jeep occupants, informing them that they were parked in the lot next to the Metro Inn on Ellis Avenue. Sarah Graves claimed that when they arrived, Rice and Blalak were talking to a black man in the motel's car park. Deadman then confronted the man and the pair got into a physical altercation. After the fight, Deadman returned to the Ford and referred to the man using racist terminology. Graves told detectives,
三名派对参与者打了个招呼就回家了，而剩下的七人则承诺成行。23岁的威廉·蒙哥马利驾驶着他的白色吉普切诺基SUV，载着18岁的约翰·赖斯、约翰·布莱拉克和20岁的迪伦·巴特勒。达里尔·迪德曼开着他的绿色福特F-250皮卡，载着萨拉·格雷夫斯和谢尔比·理查兹。在驱车前往杰克逊的途中，迪德曼和女孩们接到吉普车乘客的电话，通知他们停在埃利斯大道地铁客栈旁边的停车场里。萨拉·格雷夫斯声称，当他们到达时，赖斯和布莱拉克正在汽车旅馆的停车场里与一名黑人男子交谈。随后，迪德曼与该男子对峙，两人发生了身体冲突。冲突结束后，迪德曼回到福特车上，并用种族歧视的词汇称呼这名男子。格雷夫斯告诉侦探：
We started pulling out and the guy was walking towards us and Deadman just stepped on it. The guy slipped under the car and then I freaked out and I went into like a shock. I couldn't breathe. I couldn't say anything. I didn't know what to do. I was scared. Afterwards, Deadman called Montgomery to brag about what he had done. The two groups then reconvened at a nearby McDonald's restaurant where Deadman laughed as he surveyed the front bumper of his car. After six hours at the police station, Sarah Graves was released without charge, as was Shelby Richards. Graves was picked up by her mother, Mary, who later described her daughter as seeming scared to death. She had Sarah admitted into hospital believing that she was suicidal.
“我们开始倒车离开，那家伙朝我们走来，迪德曼就猛踩油门。那家伙滑到了车底下，然后我吓坏了，进入了一种休克状态。我喘不过气来。我什么也说不出来。我不知道该怎么办。我很害怕。”之后，迪德曼打电话给蒙哥马利，吹嘘他所做的事情。两组人随后在附近的一家麦当劳餐厅重新会合，迪德曼一边查看他汽车的前保险杠一边大笑。在警察局呆了六个小时后，萨拉·格雷夫斯被无罪释放，谢尔比·理查兹也是如此。格雷夫斯被她的母亲玛丽接走，玛丽后来形容她的女儿看起来吓得要死。她让萨拉住进了医院，因为她认为她有自杀倾向。
In the meantime, a remorseless Daryl Deadman was formally charged with Craig Anderson's murder. He posted the required 15% of his $50,000 bond securing his release pending trial. Police obtained CCTV footage from a security camera that overlooked the Ellis Avenue entrance to the car park. Both offenders' vehicles were filmed entering the lot, though only the Ford remained in view. Although the physical assault on Craig Anderson occurred off camera, multiple figures could be seen moving in and out of frame between the fight and the two cars. Before leaving, one figure believed to be Daryl Deadman was captured punching a fist in the air and was overheard by a security guard yelling white power. Even though a tree partly obscured the area where Craig was run over, Deadman's Ford could be seen steering up onto the curb and behind the tree before rising up over something and back down again. One officer said, It sent chills just watching the CCTV. I couldn't believe it. They ran Craig Anderson down like a dog.
与此同时，毫无悔意的达里尔·迪德曼被正式指控谋杀克雷格·安德森。他支付了5万美元保释金所需的15%，从而获释等待审判。警察从俯瞰停车场埃利斯大道入口的安全摄像头获取了闭路电视录像。两个违法者的车辆都被拍到进入停车场，尽管只有福特车留在视野内。尽管对克雷格·安德森的身体攻击发生在镜头之外，但在打斗和两辆车之间，可以看到多个人影在画面内外移动。在离开之前，一个被认为是达里尔·迪德曼的人被拍到将拳头向空中挥舞，并被保安听到高喊“白人力量”。尽管一棵树部分挡住了克雷格被撞倒的区域，但可以看到迪德曼的福特车开上路牙并穿过树后，然后又从某物上方升起并落回。一名警官说：“看闭路电视简直让人毛骨悚然。我简直不敢相信。他们像对待狗一样把克雷格·安德森撞倒了。”
Detectives soon learned that the assault was instigated by teenager John Rice. After arriving at the car park, Rice and fellow Jeep passenger John Blaylack had approached Craig as he tried to access his locked car. They pretended to help, only to turn on Craig once Daryl Deadman arrived. Rice, Blaylack and Deadman then confronted Craig together. Deadman referred to Craig using a racial slur and yelled, Get away from my truck. Rice threw the first punch before Deadman continued the attack. As a result, John Rice was also charged with Craig's murder. This charge was ultimately reduced to simple assault after Rice's attorney successfully argued that his client had left in the Jeep before the fatal hit-and-run took place.
侦探们很快得知，袭击是由少年约翰·赖斯煽动的。到达停车场后，赖斯和吉普车的同伴约翰·布莱拉克在克雷格试图打开锁着的车门时接近了他。他们假装帮忙，直到达里尔·迪德曼到达后才对克雷格下手。随后，赖斯、布莱拉克和迪德曼一起与克雷格对峙。迪德曼用种族歧视的词语称呼克雷格并大喊：“离我的卡车远点。”赖斯出了第一拳，随后迪德曼继续袭击。因此，约翰·赖斯也被指控谋杀克雷格。在赖斯的律师成功辩称他的客户端在致命的肇事逃逸发生之前已经乘坐吉普车离开后，这一指控最终被减轻为普通袭击。
Rice paid his $5,000 bond and was released. The apparent race-based motive for Craig's murder developed further as the investigation continued. Sarah Graves had told detectives that Daryl Deadman was a racist as she had heard him once say that he can't stand black people. Furthermore, witnesses had overheard Deadman and others yelling racial abuse at Craig, refer to him in a derogatory manner, and chant the racist slogan White Power immediately after the attack. However, the youths involved remained tight-lipped when questioned about their interactions with Craig and their reasons for being in Jackson that night. John Rice's attorney claimed that the group had gone to Jackson to buy alcohol and not to harass or assault anyone. Despite these assertions, investigators sought to present the case as a hate crime, but there wasn't enough evidence for the district attorney to proceed down that path. News of Craig Anderson's murder outraged Jackson's black community, prompting them to reach out to civil rights attorney J.D. Owens II.
赖斯支付了5000美元的保释金并被释放。随着调查的继续，克雷格谋杀案中明显的种族动机进一步显现。萨拉·格雷夫斯曾告诉侦探，达里尔·迪德曼是个种族主义者，因为她曾听他说过他无法忍受黑人。此外，目击者听到迪德曼和其他人对克雷格大喊种族侮辱，用贬损的方式称呼他，并在袭击发生后高呼种族主义口号“白人力量”。然而，涉案的年轻人当被问及他们与克雷格的互动以及那天晚上在杰克逊的原因时，仍然守口如瓶。约翰·赖斯的一名律师声称，这群人去杰克逊是为了买酒，而不是骚扰或袭击任何人。尽管有这些断言，调查人员仍试图将此案作为仇恨犯罪提交，但证据不足，无法让地方检察官沿着这条路走下去。克雷格·安德森被谋杀的消息激怒了杰克逊的黑人社区，促使他们联系了民权律师J·D·欧文斯二世。
Owens worked for the Southern Poverty Law Center, a not-for-profit organization known for taking legal action against white supremacists and other extremist groups. In an effort to establish that the crime was racially motivated, Owens hired a private investigator to conduct an independent inquiry into Craig's death. A middle-aged white male was tactically chosen for the task, as he would be able to circulate easily within the communities where the suspects lived. The PI discovered that the seven youths present for Craig's murder, along with several others, had visited Jackson on multiple occasions to conduct what they had called hunting. The process involved searching the city for vulnerable black people to harass and attack. The investigator also discovered that Daryl Deadman had relatives who belonged to white supremacist groups. J.D. Owens shared the findings with the FBI, and five days after Craig's murder, they opened an investigation of their own. They found out that a few weeks prior to Craig's death, Daryl Deadman had been robbed by a black man.
欧文斯为南方贫困法律中心工作，这是一个以对白人至上主义者和其他极端主义群体采取法律行动而闻名的非营利组织。为了确定该犯罪具有种族动机，欧文斯聘请了一名私家侦探对克雷格的死进行独立调查。一名中年的白人男性被战术性地挑选来执行这项任务，因为他能够轻松地在嫌疑人居住的社区中活动。这名私家侦探发现，出席克雷格谋杀案的七名年轻人以及其他几人曾多次访问杰克逊，进行他们所谓的“狩猎”。这个过程包括在城市中搜寻脆弱的黑人进行骚扰和袭击。调查人员还发现，达里尔·迪德曼有属于白人至上主义团体的亲属。J·D·欧文斯将这些发现分享给了联邦调查局，在克雷格遇害五天后，他们展开了自己的调查。他们发现，在克雷格死前几周，达里尔·迪德曼曾被一名黑人男子抢劫。
This supported the belief that the hit-and-run had been an intentional act by Deadman, likely motivated by revenge. Craig Anderson's funeral was held six days after his death at his former parish, the first-hired Park Baptist Church. As requested by the Anderson family, the service focused on celebrating Craig's life rather than the brutal nature of his death, and there was no mention of hate or anger. Craig's sister, Barbara, spoke of her brother's love for cooking, his sense of fashion, and his humour. She called his death untimely, and chose not to speak out against those responsible. Pastor Brian Richardson and his 17-year-old son, Jordan, were two of the few white people in attendance. Jordan attended Brandon High School with Daryl Deadman and had endured two years of violent bullying at his hands, partly because he had black friends. Earlier that year, Deadman had been arrested and convicted of misdemeanor harassment against Jordan and was on probation at the time of Craig's murder.
这支持了肇事逃逸是迪德曼的蓄意行为这一信念，很可能是出于报复动机。克雷格·安德森的葬礼在他去世六天后在他以前的教区——第一受雇公园浸信会教堂举行。正如安德森家族所要求的，礼拜的重点是庆祝克雷格的一生，而不是他死去的残酷性质，并且没有提及仇恨或愤怒。克雷格的姐姐芭芭拉谈到了她的弟弟对烹饪的热爱、他的时尚感和他的幽默感。她称他的死是不合时宜的，并选择不对那些负有责任的人大声指责。牧师布莱恩·理查森和他的17岁儿子乔丹是仅有的几名出席的白人之一。乔丹与达里尔·迪德曼一起在布兰登高中上学，并忍受了他长达两年的暴力欺凌，部分原因是他有黑人朋友。今年早些时候，迪德曼因对乔丹进行轻罪骚扰而被捕并定罪，在克雷格被谋杀时正处于缓刑期。
On July 6, 2011, Daryl Deadman was called back to court for a bond revocation hearing. The prosecution were now confidently calling the murder of Craig Anderson a hate crime. After presenting the evidence that supported their position, the prosecution put forward that Deadman had left the party in the early hours of June 26 with the intention of going in search of a black person to attack. Deadman's attorney rejected these allegations, but the judge was satisfied with the evidence presented and a Deadman's bond was increased from $50,000 to $800,000. Unable to secure the payment, Deadman was placed in police custody to await trial. By this stage, the CCTV footage from the Metro Inn parking lot had been leaked to the press and broadcast on televised news reports throughout the country. As a result, Deadman was isolated in jail for his own safety. Meanwhile, the assistant police chief told CNN reporters that Craig's death was an isolated incident and denied that the attack was part of a bigger story.
2011年7月6日，达里尔·迪德曼被传唤回法庭参加保释撤销听证会。控方现在有信心地称克雷格·安德森的谋杀案为仇恨犯罪。在出示支持其立场的证据后，控方提出迪德曼在6月26日凌晨离开派对，意图寻找一名黑人进行袭击。迪德曼的律师驳回了这些指控，但法官对提交的证据感到满意，迪德曼的保释金从5万美元增加到80万美元。由于无法筹集这笔款项，迪德曼被置于警察拘留中等待审判。此时，地铁客栈停车场的闭路电视录像已被泄露给媒体，并在全国各地的电视新闻报道中播出。因此，为了他自身的安全，迪德曼在监狱中被隔离。与此同时，助理警察局长告诉CNN记者，克雷格的死是一起孤立事件，并否认这次袭击是更大故事的一部分。
CNN also spoke with the Jordan Richardson, the teenager Deadman had been previously convicted of harassing. Jordan said that Deadman always had a look of no conscience and carried around this backpack of hatred. Jordan's father, Pastor Brian Richardson, told CNN he had warned his son about Deadman's volatility and had been worried that Deadman might go as far as to kill Jordan. Pastor Richardson had told the police it was painfully clear that Deadman was going to injure someone severely or possibly kill someone. Other Brandon High School students told CNN that Deadman and his friends bullied white classmates who had black friends and used the racist language in real life and online. He had protested at school when Barack Obama was elected America's first African American president and referred to him using racist insults on social media. According to the students, school administrators mostly looked the other way as the racial hatred and bullying intensified. When CNN contacted Brandon High administrators, a spokesperson told them that the school took bullying very seriously and had no record of any incidents involving Deadman.
CNN还采访了乔丹·理查森，这个迪德曼先前被判骚扰的青少年。乔丹说，迪德曼总是有一种没有良心的表情，随身带着这个充满仇恨的背包。乔丹的父亲，布莱恩·理查森牧师告诉CNN，他曾警告过他的儿子迪德曼的反复无常，并一直担心迪德曼可能会走得太远而杀死乔丹。理查森牧师曾告诉警察，很痛心地清楚迪德曼会严重伤害某人或可能杀死某人。布兰登高中的其他学生告诉CNN，迪德曼和他的朋友们欺凌有黑人朋友的白人同学，在现实生活和网上使用种族主义语言。当巴拉克·奥巴马当选为美国第一位非裔美国总统时，他在学校抗议，并在社交媒体上用种族主义侮辱来称呼他。据学生们说，随着种族仇恨和欺凌的加剧，学校管理人员大多视而不见。当CNN联系布兰登高中的管理人员时，一位发言人告诉他们，学校非常重视欺凌行为，并且没有任何涉及迪德曼的事件记录。
A former friend revealed that Deadman and his group were referred to as the Brandon Boys and were known for going out at night to target black individuals. Ken Johnson, the manager of a service station in Brandon where Deadman and his friends often hung out, told CNN. That seemed like every word that came out of their mouth was the N word. Ken once told the group to mind their behavior after he overheard them say that black people were taking over their town. Ken told CNN. Deadman made it well known that he didn't like a gay or black people. He talked about Jackson being a predominantly black city and said his parents grew up and moved away because of all these black people. Many Brandon locals were outraged that their town was being accused of racism and told reporters that they didn't view Craig Anderson's death as a hate crime.
一位前朋友透露，迪德曼和他的团伙被称为“布兰登男孩”，并以夜间出动针对黑人个人而闻名。肯·约翰逊是布兰登一家服务站的经理，迪德曼和他的朋友经常在那里闲逛，他告诉CNN：“似乎他们嘴里说出的每一个字都是N字。”肯曾有一次告诉这群人注意他们的行为，因为他无意中听到他们说黑人正在接管他们的镇子。肯告诉CNN：“迪德曼让人清楚地知道他不喜欢同性恋或黑人。他谈到杰克逊是一个以黑人为主的城市，并说他的父母因为所有这些黑人而长大并搬走了。”许多布兰登当地人对他们的城镇被指控为种族主义感到愤怒，并告诉记者他们不认为克雷格·安德森的死是一起仇恨犯罪。
While they agreed that Deadman had violated the law, they didn't believe he had targeted Craig because of his race. A white senior from Brandon High told the Jackson Free Press that the residents of Brandon were very down to worth and that she was worried Craig's death would reflect poorly on them. Quote, Brandon is one of the top places to live in the country. There is nothing bad about Brandon. It's a shame the crime happened. Deadman's younger sister told The New York Times, we're just country and whoever comes here, we welcome everybody. This whole thing is getting blown out of proportion. Deadman's uncle described his nephew as a good boy from a happy-go-lucky family who got involved with the wrong crowd. A relative of John Rice, Deadman's co-accused, took to Facebook to say that Rice wasn't a murderer but had fallen victim to trial by media and was suffering from, quote, reverse racism. Another Facebook user echoed this sentiment, writing, if this was the other way around and a black guy ran over a white boy, it would not be a hate crime. Baseless rumors spread around Brandon that Craig's death was drug-related, prompting Michael Teasley, the white president of Jackson State University's chapter of the National Association for the Advancement of Colored People, to speak out.
虽然他们同意迪德曼违反了法律，但他们不认为他因为克雷格的种族而将其作为目标。布兰登高中的一名白人高年级学生告诉《杰克逊自由报》，布兰登的居民非常脚踏实地，她担心克雷格的死会给他们带来不好的反映。“引文：布兰登是全国最适合居住的地方之一。布兰登没有任何不好的地方。发生这起犯罪真是一个遗憾。”迪德曼的妹妹告诉《纽约时报》：“我们只是乡下人，无论谁来这里，我们都欢迎所有人。这整件事被夸大了。”迪德曼的叔叔将他的侄女婿描述为一个来自快乐家庭的好男孩，却误交了损友。迪德曼的同案被告约翰·赖的一位亲属在Facebook上发帖称，赖斯不是杀人犯，而是沦为了舆论审判的受害者，并遭受了“引文：反向种族主义”。另一位Facebook用户也呼应了这种情绪，写道：“如果情况反过来，一个黑人撞死了一个白男孩，这就不会是一次仇恨犯罪。”关于克雷格的死与毒品有关的毫无根据的谣言在布兰登流传，促使全国有色人种协进会杰克逊州立大学分会白人主席迈克尔·蒂斯利大声疾呼。
Michael, who was a reformed racist himself, stated, it's much easier for Rankin County to blame the black man than take responsibility for this crime. Right now, the problem is in their churches, homes, and schools. This doesn't have anything to do with a drug deal gone bad. They are looking for an excuse to make themselves feel better. Gerald Rose, founder of the New Order National Human Rights Organization, said that the situation could be used to provoke level-headed discussions about race relations, quote, When I saw the video, I shed tears. That could have been me, or it could have been my sons. We want to call for a healing process, and at the same time, we are aware racism is still alive. I can't believe stuff like this is going on in the year 2011. On August 14, 2011, more than 500 people, including clergymen, elected officials, and supporters of all races, gathered at the New Horizon Church in Jackson to march against racial injustice. T-shirts were distributed amongst the protesters, printed with the slogan, Not in My City. They marched through Jackson singing, We Shall Overcome, and This Little Light of Mine, before gathering in the Metro Wing Car Park for a candlelight vigil. Rabbi Valerie Cohen told the attendees, We are here to unify and to teach ourselves and our children, and everyone out there, that love is a better way to live. We are here to get beyond hatred.
迈克尔曾经是一个改过自新的种族主义者，他表示：“兰金县更容易把责任推卸给黑人，而不是为这起犯罪承担责任。现在，问题出在他们的教堂、家庭和学校里。这与毒品交易变坏没有任何关系。他们只是在寻找借口让自己感觉好一点。”新秩序人权组织创始人杰拉尔德·罗斯表示，这种情况可以用来引发关于种族关系的冷静讨论，“引文：当我看到这段视频时，我流下了眼泪。那可能是我，或者可能是我的儿子们。我们想要呼吁一个治愈的过程，与此同时，我们意识到种族主义仍然活着。我简直不敢相信在2011年还会发生这样的事情。”2011年8月14日，包括神职人员、民选官员和各族支持者在内的500多人聚集在杰克逊的新地平线教堂，游行抗议种族不平等。抗议者分发了印有“不在我的城市”口号的T恤。他们唱着“我们一定会克服”和“我这小小的光芒”穿过杰克逊游行，然后聚集在地铁客栈停车场举行烛光守夜活动。拉比瓦莱里·科恩对出席者说：“我们在这里是为了团结，并教导我们自己和我们的孩子，以及那里的每个人，爱是更好的生活方式。我们在这里是为了超越仇恨。”
Craig's husband, to James, was in too much emotional pain to attend the vigil. He told Buzzfeed News that following the murder, he had purchased a gun in fear that Craig's attackers would also come for him. He blamed himself for not being with Craig on the night he was killed, saying, I should have been there. I always protected him. That was my job. James lost his faith and stopped going to church and to work, instead spending his days crying in bed with the lights off and the curtains drawn. As a result, the couple's four-year-old adopted son went to live with the James's mother. James avoided the news as he didn't want to see the CCTV footage of Craig's death. One afternoon, James was driving his adopted son to his mother's house when he said, You can't go that way. That's where dead men killed Craig. Stunned, James looked around and realized that they were passing the Metro Wing car park. He asked his son how he knew what happened there, to which the child responded, I saw it on TV. Almost two months after Craig Anderson's death, Daryl Deadman's murder charge was upgraded to capital murder.
克雷格的丈夫詹姆斯因悲痛欲绝而无法出席守夜活动。他告诉《BuzzFeed新闻》，谋杀案发生后，他买了一把枪，因为害怕克雷格的袭击者也会来找他。他责备自己在克雷格被杀的那晚没有陪在他身边，并说：“我本应该在那里的。我总是保护他。那是我的工作。”詹姆斯失去了信仰，不再去教堂和上班，而是在拉上窗帘、关着灯的床上哭泣度日。结果，这对夫妇4岁的养子去和詹姆斯的母亲住在一起。詹姆斯避开新闻，因为他不想看到克雷格死时的闭路电视画面。一天下午，詹姆斯正开车载着他的养子去他母亲家，这时养子说：“你不能走那条路。那是死人杀死克雷格的地方。”惊呆了的詹姆斯环顾四周，意识到他们正路过地铁客栈停车场。他问他的儿子怎么知道那里发生了什么，对此孩子回答说：“我在电视上看到了。”在克雷格·安德森死后近两个月，达里尔·迪德曼的谋杀罪名被升级为谋杀罪。
Under Mississippi law, a capital murder charge arises where the circumstances of an unlawful killing includes one of the prescribed list of aggravating factors. The relevant aggravating factor in the Craig Anderson case was that Craig had been killed during the commission of a robbery, as Deadman had stolen his phone, wallet, and wedding ring. If convicted of capital murder, there was the possibility that Deadman would face the death penalty. Put a spring in your step with Sirius XM. Shake off the winter blues with over 425 channels of ad-free music, plus play-by-play sports, comedy, exclusive talk, world-class news, and popular podcasts. Subscribe to the streaming platinum plan to get your first three months for free. Visit SiriusXM.ca for details. SiriusXM, everything you want to hear lives here.
根据密西西比州的法律，当非法杀害的 circonstances 包括规定的一列加重情节之一时，就会产生谋杀罪名。克雷格·安德森案中相关的加重情节是，克雷格在实施抢劫期间被杀，因为迪德曼偷了他的手机、钱包和结婚戒指。如果被判谋杀罪，迪德曼可能会面临死刑。通过Sirius XM让你的生活充满活力。摆脱冬日的忧郁，拥有超过425个无广告音乐频道，外加现场转播体育赛事、喜剧、独家访谈、世界级新闻和热门播客。订阅流媒体白金计划，前三个月免费。访问SiriusXM.ca了解详情。SiriusXM，你所有想听的一切都在这里。
After interviewing over 250 people and using grand-dury subpoenas and social media to obtain information, the FBI discovered a culture of racism and a pattern of hate crimes committed by Daryl Deadman and his friends in the weeks leading up to Craig Anderson's death. Since April 2011, the youths had made multiple trips into Jackson, or what they refer to as Jafrica, a racially derogatory portmanteau combining Jackson and Africa. While there, they harassed the black individuals whom they perceived to be homeless or under the influence of drugs or alcohol, as they believed these targets would be less likely to resist or report their attacks to police. Investigators uncovered four separate incidents involving some of the youths present during Craig Anderson's attack. On one occasion, Daryl Deadman, John Rice, John Blalak, William Montgomery, John Rice's brother, 20-year-old Robert Rice, and 20-year-old Jonathan Gascamp drove into Jackson armed with a handgun. The group found an intoxicated black man alone near a golf course and beat him until he begged for his life. Gascamp also threatened to shoot the man. On another occasion, Deadman, Blalak, Montgomery, and the Rice brothers were driving through Jackson when they spotted a black male pedestrian near a gas station. Robert Rice, who was driving Montgomery's Jeep, accelerated in the direction of the man and nearly ran him down. Witnesses said that if the man hadn't moved, he would have been hit.
在对250多人进行了访谈，并利用大陪审团传票和社交媒体获取信息后，联邦调查局（FBI）发现在克雷格·安德森（Craig Anderson）遇害前的几周里，达里尔·迪德曼（Daryl Deadman）及其朋友们滋生了一种种族主义文化，并实施了一系列仇恨犯罪。自2011年4月以来，这些年轻人曾多次前往杰克逊（Jackson），或者他们口中的“杰фри卡”（Jafrica，一个将杰克逊和非洲结合在一起的带有种族侮辱色彩的混成词）。在那里，他们骚扰那些被他们认为无家可图或受毒品或酒精影响的黑人，因为他们认为这些目标不太可能反抗或向警方报案。调查人员发现了与克雷格·安德森遇袭时在场的某些年轻人有关的四起独立事件。有一次，达里尔·迪德曼、约翰·赖斯（John Rice）、约翰·布拉拉克（John Blalak）、威廉·蒙哥马利（William Montgomery）、约翰·赖斯的弟弟20岁的罗伯特·赖斯（Robert Rice）以及20岁的乔纳森·加斯坎普（Jonathan Gascamp）携手枪开车进入杰克逊。这群人发现一名醉酒的黑人独自在高尔夫球场附近，便对其实施殴打，直到他恳求饶命。加斯坎普还威胁要开枪射杀这名男子。另有一次，迪德曼、布拉拉克、蒙哥马利和赖斯兄弟开车穿过杰克逊时，在一家加油站附近发现了一名黑人男性行人。驾驶蒙哥马利吉普车的罗伯特·赖斯加速朝该男子冲去，险些将他撞倒。目击者称，如果该男子没有躲开，他就会被撞到。
Another time, Blalak, Montgomery, the Rice brothers, and Shelby Richards lured a black man into believing they wanted to buy drugs, but instead, Blalak punched him in the face. The fourth incident involved Blalak and Montgomery, along with Dylan Butler, who was also present on the night of Craig's murder, 21-year-old Joseph Dominic, and an unnamed fifth person. Together, they hurled beer bottles at black pedestrians, causing one man to fall to the ground. They also stopped at a sporting goods stall and purchased a slingshot, then took turns shooting metal ball bearings at any black people they encountered, including those who were visibly impaired and a teenage boy riding his bicycle. The FBI also re-interviewed Sarah Graves, the teenage girl who had been riding in Daryl Deadman's Ford at the time of Craig Anderson's murder. Graves had previously provided the police with a summary of events leading up to the killing, but admitted to the FBI that she had been lying about her role on the night and had withheld information. She now admitted to being one of the main driving forces behind recruiting party goers to take the hunting trip into Jackson that night. She, along with Daryl Deadman, Shelby Richards, and John Blalak, had encouraged others to join them for a trip into Africa to, quote, fuck with some black people.
还有一次，布拉拉克、蒙哥马利、赖斯兄弟和谢尔比·理查兹（Shelby Richards）诱使一名黑人男子相信他们想买毒品，但相反，布拉拉克一拳打在了他的脸上。第四起事件涉及布拉拉克和蒙哥马利，以及在克雷格遇害当晚也在场的迪伦·巴特勒（Dylan Butler）、21岁的约瑟夫·多米尼克（Joseph Dominic）和一个未透露姓名的第五个人。他们一起向黑人行人投掷啤酒瓶，导致一名男子倒地。他们还在一家体育用品摊位停留，买了一个弹弓，然后轮流用金属轴承射击他们遇到的任何黑人，包括那些明显神志不清的人和一个骑自行车的少年。联邦调查局还重新面谈了莎拉·格雷夫斯（Sarah Graves），这个在克雷格·安德森遇害时坐在达里尔·迪德曼的福特汽车里的十几岁女孩。格雷夫斯此前曾向警方提供了一份谋杀案前夕事件的摘要，但她向联邦调查局承认，她在当晚自己的角色上撒了谎，并隐瞒了信息。她现在承认自己是招募派对参与者在当晚进行杰克逊狩猎之旅的主要推动力之一。她与达里尔·迪德曼、谢尔比·理查兹和约翰·布拉拉克一起，鼓励其他人加入他们去“非洲”旅行，用他们的话说，是“去整几个黑人”。
Blalak also gathered up empty glass bottles from the party to use as projectiles. The FBI concluded that although the seven individuals who went into Jackson in the early hours of Sunday June 26 might not have had a specific plan to kill, they definitely intended to harm or harass. Montgomery had driven the Jeep into the city, while Blalak, Butler, and John Rice threw bottles at black pedestrians. When they spotted Craig Anderson stranded by his locked car, they perceived him as being drunk. After phoning Deadman's group to tell them to come to the parking lot, Blalak and Rice approached Craig under the guise of offering assistance. They conversed with Craig in order to stall the situation until Deadman, Graves, and Richards arrived in the Ford. Richards encouraged her boyfriend, Deadman, to assault Craig. Rice threw the initial punch before Deadman continued the assault, which left Craig severely battered but alive.
布拉拉克还从派对上收集了空玻璃瓶作为投掷物。联邦调查局得出结论，尽管在6月26日星期日凌晨进入杰克逊的这七个人可能没有具体的杀人计划，但他们绝对有伤害或骚扰的意图。蒙哥马利驾驶吉普车进入市区，而布拉拉克、巴特勒和约翰·赖斯则向黑人行人投掷瓶子。当他们发现克雷格·安德森被困在他那辆锁着的汽车旁时，他们认为他喝醉了。在打电话给迪德曼的团伙让他们来停车场后，布拉拉克和赖斯以提供帮助为幌子接近了克雷格。他们与克雷格交谈以拖延时间，直到迪德曼、格雷夫斯和理查兹乘福特车赶到。理查兹鼓励她的男友迪德曼袭击克雷格。赖斯打出了第一拳，随后迪德曼继续殴打，这使得克雷格受到重伤但仍活着。
Deadman then got back in his car and drove over Craig, while he and his girlfriend shouted racial abuse out the window. It remained unclear which of the youths in the Jeep first yelled out white power, but it was Deadman who repeated the chant. The FBI also discovered that the racial violence carried out by the young offenders was well known in Brandon. In fact, dozens of white teens from the area knew about the group's actions, but did nothing to stop them. On September 6, 2011, Craig Anderson's family filed a civil wrongful death suit against a Daryl Deadman, John Rice, Sarah Graves, Shelby Richards, William Montgomery, Dylan Butler, and a John Blalak. The suit alleged that while all seven of the youths weren't directly responsible for assaulting and killing Craig, they were all negligent because they didn't try to stop the attack, provide any assistance to Craig, or call the police. Craig's mother and siblings, who were listed as plaintiffs, stated they would forever be deprived of Craig's comfort, services, financial support, and companionship. Given that Mississippi didn't acknowledge same-sex marriage at the time, James was unable to join the family's civil claim, as he wasn't considered to have any legal standing in the matter.
然后迪德曼回到车里，从克雷格身上开车碾压过去，他和他的女朋友在车窗外大声叫喊种族侮辱言论。目前尚不清楚吉普车中的哪个年轻人最先喊出“白人至上”，但确实是迪德曼重复了这个口号。联邦调查局还发现，这些年轻罪犯实施的种族暴力在布兰登（Brandon）是众所周知的。事实上，当地数十名白人青少年知道该团伙的行径，但什么也没做来阻止他们。2011年9月6日，克雷格·安德森的家人对达里尔·迪德曼、约翰·赖斯、莎拉·格雷夫斯、谢尔比·理查兹、威廉·蒙哥马利、迪伦·巴特勒和约翰·布拉拉克提起了一起民事过失致死诉讼。诉讼称，虽然这七名年轻人并非全部直接对袭击和杀害克雷格负责，但他们都有疏忽，因为他们没有试图阻止袭击、没有为克雷格提供任何援助，也没有报警。作为原告被列出的克雷格的母亲和兄弟姐妹表示，他们将永远被剥夺克雷格的安慰、服务、经济支持和陪伴。鉴于密西西比州当时不承认同性婚姻，詹姆斯无法加入家人的民事诉讼，因为他在这件事上被认为没有任何法律地位。
While awaiting trial, Daryl Deadman penned a letter to his younger sister. In it, he claimed that he had committed himself to Jesus and warned her to stay away from trouble. He blamed his actions on alcohol and his friendship group, writing, My so-called friends got me in here. As Deadman's capital murderer Raymond approached, Craig's sister, Barbara, wrote a letter to the district attorney on behalf of her family, requesting that the death penalty be taken off the table. She explained that the Andersons were opposed to capital punishment, in part because of their Christian beliefs, and because of its historic association against people of color. The letter stated, Those responsible for Craig's death not only ended the life of a talented and wonderful man, they also have caused our family unspeakable pain and grief.
在等待审判期间，达里尔·迪德曼给他的小妹妹写了一封信。信中，他声称自己已经皈依耶稣，并警告她远离麻烦。他将自己的行为归咎于酒精和他的朋友圈，写道：“我所谓的朋侪把我弄进这里的。”随着迪德曼的谋杀案审判临近，克雷格的妹妹芭芭拉（Barbara）代表她的家人给地区检察官写了一封信，请求取消死刑。她解释说，安德森一家反对死刑，部分是因为他们的基督教信仰，以及由于死刑历史上针对有色人种的关联。信中写道：“那些对克雷格之死负责的人不仅结束了一个才华横溢、心地善良的人的生命，还给我们的家人带来了无法言喻的痛苦和悲伤。”
But our loss will not be lessened by the state taking the life of another. As Coretta Scott King stated in explaining her opposition to the death penalty, an evil deed is not redeemed by an evil deed of retaliation. Executing Craig's killers will not help balance the scales. On September 21, 2011, Deadman entered a plea of not guilty and was ordered to remain in custody until his trial commenced early the following year. In the months leading up to the event, a dispute began over whether Deadman should be tried in Jackson. The prosecution wanted the trial to be held where the crime occurred, as the jury pool would be predominantly black. But Deadman's lawyers wanted to move it to another jurisdiction with a larger white population. The debate came to an abrupt end when on March 21, 2012, Daryl Deadman pleaded guilty to the charge of capital murder.
但我们的损失不会因为国家夺走另一个人的生命而减轻。正如科雷塔·斯科特·金（Coretta Scott King）在解释她对死刑的反对时所说，邪恶的行为不会通过报复的邪恶行为来救赎。处决克雷格的凶手无助于平衡天平。2011年9月21日，迪德曼对指控做出了无罪抗辩，并被下令继续拘留，直到第二年初审判开始。在事件发生前的几个月里，关于是否应该在杰克逊审判迪德曼产生了一场争端。检方希望在犯罪发生地举行审判，因为那里的陪审团成员将主要由黑人组成。但迪德曼的律师希望将其转移到白人人口较多的另一个司法管辖区。这场辩论在2012年3月21日戛然而止，当时达里尔·迪德曼对谋杀罪名表示认罪。
He delivered a pre-prepared statement in which he apologized to the Anderson family and asked for their forgiveness. I take full responsibility for my actions on that night. I did a very malicious thing for no reason. Deadman told the court that he was a changed man who had found religion since his arrest and said, I was young and dumb, ignorant and full of hatred. I chose to go down the wrong path. Craig's sister Barbara delivered a statement to the court on behalf of her family that read, These last few months have been very difficult. We cried, we wept, we reminisced about our beloved brother Craig, a loss I cannot even explain. Craig was a big hearted person, one who loved his fellow man, caring, family oriented and a big sense of humor. My brother Craig would give you the shirt off of his back. We, the Anderson family, are praying for racial reconciliation not only in Mississippi, but all over this land and country.
他宣读了一份事先准备好的声明，在声明中他向安德森一家道歉并请求他们的原谅。“我对那天晚上的行为承担全部责任。我无缘无故地做了一件非常恶毒的事情。”迪德曼对法庭说，他是一个改变了的人，自被捕以来已经找到了宗教信仰，并说：“我当时年轻、愚蠢、无知且充满仇恨。我选择走了一条错误的道路。”克雷格的妹妹芭芭拉代表她的家人在法庭上宣读了一份声明，其中写道：“这几个月非常艰难。我们哭了，我们流泪了，我们怀念我们挚爱的兄弟克雷格，这种痛苦我甚至无法解释。克雷格是一个心地善良的人，一个热爱同胞、有爱心、顾家并且极具幽默感的人。我的兄弟克雷格会把身上的衬衫脱下来给你。我们安德森一家正在为种族和解祈祷，不仅在密西西比州，而且在这片土地和国家的各个角落。”
We are praying that the defendant, Deadman and his family find peace. Under Mississippi law, a defendant can be given a double sentence if their actions are found to be a hate crime. Presiding judge Jeff Weale did exactly that, sentencing Daryl Deadman to two life sentences to be served concurrently. Judge Weale stated, Mr. Deadman, having heard your admissions, the very walls of this courthouse cry out for justice. You have admitted killing a man simply because of his race. Your prejudice has brought shame upon you and placed a great stain on the state of Mississippi. Whatever excuse you may offer for what you have done, forget that. There is no excuse you can offer to the family of Mr. Anderson or to your fellow Mississippians who have to try to reconcile the horrible damage you have caused. All the hard work we have done to move our state forward has been stained by you, a stain which will take years to fade.
“我们祈祷被告迪德曼和他的家人能找到平静。”根据密西西比州的法律，如果被告的行为被认定为仇恨犯罪，可以被判处双倍刑期。主审法官杰夫·韦尔（Jeff Weale）正是这样做的，判处达里尔·迪德曼两项终身监禁，同时执行。韦尔法官说：“迪德曼先生，在听取了你的供词之后，这座法院的斑斑墙壁都在呼唤正义。你已经承认仅仅因为一个人的种族而杀死了一个人。你的偏见给你带来了耻辱，并给密西西比州留下了巨大的污点。无论你为自己的所作所为借口什么，都忘了吧。你无法向安德森先生的家人，也无法向那些必须试图调解你造成的可怕损害的密西西比同胞们做出任何借口。我们为推动我们州向前发展所做的一切努力都被你抹上了污点，这个污点需要数年时间才能消退。”
Addressing the Anderson family directly, Judge Weale then said, Know that Mississippians think about this senseless crime the way you think about it. With all her troubled past, the state of Mississippi stands with you today and condemns this despicable crime and says, There is no excuse for this. After the sentencing, the District Attorney of Jackson said he expected further charges to be placed against the Deadman, with more arrests to come. Quote, This is just the beginning. That same day, Daryl Deadman, John Rice and Dylan Butler were all charged with one count of conspiracy and one of committing hate crimes in violation of the Federal Hate Crimes Prevention Act of 2009.
韦尔法官随后直接对安德森一家说：“要知道，密西西比人对这起毫无意义的犯罪的看法和你们一样。尽管密西西比州有着动荡的过去，但今天她依然站在你们这一边，谴责这起卑鄙的罪行，并说：‘这没有任何借口。’”宣判后，杰克逊地区检察官表示，他预计将对迪德曼提出更多指控，还会有更多逮捕行动。引用原话：“这只是开始。”当天，达里尔·迪德曼、约翰·赖斯和迪伦·巴特勒都被控一项共谋罪和一项违反2009年《联邦仇恨犯罪预防法》实施仇恨犯罪的罪名。
These charges were in relation to their history of racially motivated crime, including the murder of Craig Anderson. All three young men denied being racist or being raised to have a hatred of African Americans. Regardless, the next day of March 22, 2012, they each pleaded guilty, marking the first time that the Hate Crimes Prevention Act had ever been used in a case where the defendant's actions resulted in a victim's death. They appeared in court for sentencing in February 2015, three years and seven months after Craig Anderson's murder. Judge Carlton Reeves, the second black federal judge in Mississippi's history, presided. James prepared a statement to be read on his behalf during proceedings, as he still couldn't bear to speak publicly about his husband's murder. It read, You all don't have a clue what you have really done to my family in committing this terrible crime.
这些指控与他们有针对性的种族动机犯罪历史有关，包括谋杀克雷格·安德森。这三名年轻人都否认自己是种族主义者或从小就被培养对非裔美国人的仇恨。无论如何，在2012年3月22日的第二天，他们都表示认罪，这标志着《仇恨犯罪预防法》首次被用于被告行为导致受害者死亡的案件中。2015年2月，即克雷格·安德森遇害三年零七个月后，他们出庭接受宣判。密西西比州历史上第二位黑人联邦法官卡尔顿·里夫斯（Carlton Reeves）担任主审法官。詹姆斯准备了一份声明，在诉讼程序期间由他人代为宣读，因为他仍然无法公开谈论他丈夫的谋杀案。声明写道：“你们根本不知道自己在犯下这起可怕罪行时对我的家庭真正做了什么。”
James Craig Anderson was a great man. He was a man who loved his family and was a great provider to our son and me. We had a great life and we miss him so much. Since his death, our lives have been turned upside down. James spoke of the detrimental impact Craig's murder had on his own mental health, his inability to work, and the challenges he had since faced as a single parent. Quote, My heart gets so heavy at times because I feel like a failure because I couldn't keep up the things Craig did for us. We were always there for each other. We supported each other and we confided in each other.
詹姆斯·克雷格·安德森是一个伟大的人。他是一个热爱家庭的人，也是我们儿子和我的伟大顶梁柱。我们曾有过美好的生活，我们非常想念他。自从他去世以来，我们的生活被彻底颠覆了。詹姆斯谈到了克雷格的谋杀对他的心理健康造成的负面影响、他无工作能力以及他自那以后作为单亲父母所面临的挑战。“我的心有时变得非常沉重，因为我觉得自己是个失败者，因为我无法维持克雷格为我们做的事情。我们总是彼此相伴。我们互相支持，我们彼此倾诉。”
I wish none of you would ever see daylight again. There is no room on earth for people like you. Judge Carlton Reeves delivered a long and powerful sentencing speech that touched on the state's troubled past with lynchings and racial injustice. Quote, On June 26, 2011, four days short of his 49th birthday, the blood of James Craig Anderson was added to Mississippi's soil. New generations have attempted to pull Mississippi from the abyss of moral depravity in which it once so proudly floundered in. Despite much progress and the efforts of the new generations, these three defendants are before me today. They and their co-conspirators ripped off the scab of the healing scars of Mississippi, causing her to bleed again. There is absolutely no doubt that in the view of the court, the victims were targeted because of their race. The simple fact is that what turned these children into criminal defendants was their joint decision to act on racial hatred.
我希望你们当中没有一个人能再次见到天日。世界上没有容纳你们这样的人的空间。卡尔顿·里夫斯法官发表了一篇漫长而有力的量刑演讲，谈到了该州充满动荡的过去，涉及林奇私刑和种族不公正。引用原话：“在2011年6月26日，即他49岁生日四天前，詹姆斯·克雷格·安德森的鲜血洒在了密西西比州的土地上。新一代人曾试图将密西西比从它曾经骄傲地堕落其中的道德堕落深渊中拉出来。尽管取得了很大进展并做出了新一代人的努力，但这三名被告今天还是站在了我面前。他们和他们的同谋撕开了密西西比愈合伤疤的结痂，导致她再次流血。毫无疑问，在法院看来，受害者是被当作目标因为他们的种族。简单的事实是，把这些孩子变成刑事被告的是他们根据种族仇恨采取行动的共同决定。”
In the eyes of these defendants and their co-conspirators, the victims were doomed at birth. Their genetic makeup made them targets. On top of the two life sentences Daryl Deadman had received for the state capital murder charge, Judge Reeves sentenced him to an additional 50 years in prison for his federal hate crimes. Deadman would first serve his 50-year sentence in a federal prison and then be moved to a state facility to serve out his two life sentences. John Rice, who had instigated the unprovoked attack on Craig, was given 18 years and four months in prison. Dylan Butler, who was present but didn't participate, was sentenced to seven years. Acting Assistant Attorney General Vanita Gupta said that these sentences proved that the Department of Justice would vigorously pursue individuals who committed racially motivated assaults and would, quote, cast a broad net to ensure that all who commit such acts are brought to justice. William Montgomery, who had driven the Jeep on the night of Craig Anderson's murder and had also participated in other hunting expeditions, was also charged with one count of conspiracy to commit a hate crime and one count of committing a hate crime.
在这些被告及其同谋眼中，受害者一出生就注定要灭亡。他们的基因构成使他们成为了目标。除了达里尔·迪德曼因州谋杀罪名已被判处两项终身监禁外，里夫斯法官还因其联邦仇恨犯罪判处他额外的50年监禁。迪德曼将首先在联邦监狱服满50年刑期，然后被转移到州立监狱服完他的两项终身监禁。挑起对克雷格无端袭击的约翰·赖斯被判处18年零4个月监禁。在场但未参与的迪伦·巴特勒被判处7年监禁。代理助理司法部长瓦妮塔·古普塔（Vanita Gupta）表示，这些判决证明司法部将大力追捕实施种族动机袭击的个人，并且会用引用原话的话来说“撒下一张大网，确保所有犯下此类行为的人都被绳之以法”。威廉·蒙哥马利在克雷格·安德森遇害当晚驾驶吉普车并参与了其他狩猎远征，也被指控犯有一项共谋实施仇恨犯罪罪和一项实施仇恨犯罪罪。
He was sentenced to 18 years and nine months in prison. Jonathan Gaskamp, who participated in the golf course attack and made threats to kill, was also charged with one count of conspiracy and one count of committing hate crimes. He was sentenced to four years. He was one of three people charged for their participation in the racist gang, but who was not present for Craig Anderson's murder. Another who was not present for Craig's murder, Joseph Dominic, struck a deal to waive the grand jury indictment and in return pleaded guilty to one count of conspiracy to commit a hate crime. He was sentenced to four years. Judge Carlton Reeves acknowledged the court's belief that if it wasn't for Craig Anderson's death, the youths would have returned to Jackson to continue their mission to harm. The remaining members of the racist gang, John Blalak, Shelby Richards and Sarah Graves, were each charged with committing a hate crime against Craig Anderson, which carried a possible life sentence.
他被判处18年零9个月监禁。乔纳森·加斯坎普参与了高尔夫球场袭击并发出杀戮威胁，也被控一项共谋罪和一项仇恨犯罪罪。他被判处四年监禁。他是因参与种族主义黑帮而被起诉但未在克雷格·安德森谋杀案现场的三人之一。另一位未在克雷格谋杀现场的约瑟夫·多米尼克达成了免除大陪审团起诉的协议，作为交换，他承认犯有一项共谋实施仇恨犯罪罪。他被判处四年监禁。卡尔顿·里夫斯法官承认法院的信念：如果不是因为克雷格·安德森的死，这些年轻人本会返回杰克逊继续他们伤害的任务。种族主义黑帮的其余成员约翰·布拉拉克、谢尔比·理查兹和莎拉·格雷夫斯分别被控对克雷格·安德森实施仇恨犯罪，这面临着终身监禁的可能性。
They, along with the John Rice, were also charged with willfully conspiring to cause bodily harm to African Americans in Jackson. Blalak and Robert Rice also received charges for the attacks leading up to Craig's murder, including for carrying a firearm. Shelby Richards and Sarah Graves faced additional charges for enlisting others to commit hate crimes, and in the case of Graves, for lying to the FBI to conceal the fact that the crime was racially motivated. Blalak, Robert Rice, Richards and Graves cited drunken judgment, youthful foolishness and peer pressure from Daryl Deadman for their participation in the attacks. They each pleaded not guilty and were released on a $100,000 unsecured bond pending trial. However, several months later, all four changed their pleas to guilty. Prior to sentencing, Sarah Graves' mother, Mary, wrote to the court asking for leniency, saying that she didn't raise her daughter to be a racist. Unbeknown to Mary, Sarah had already written to the court to say that her racist views had formed during her childhood, as her mother frequently used hateful racist language at home.
他们以及约翰·赖斯还被指控蓄意共谋对杰克逊的非裔美国人造成身体伤害。布拉拉克和罗伯特·赖斯还因克雷格谋杀案前的袭击受到指控，包括携带枪支。谢尔比·理查兹和莎拉·格雷夫斯因煽动他人实施仇恨犯罪而面临额外指控，在格雷夫斯的情况下，还包括向联邦调查局撒谎以掩盖该罪行具有种族动机的事实。布拉拉克、罗伯特·赖斯、理查兹和格雷夫斯将他们的参与归咎于酒后判断力低下、青春期的愚蠢以及来自达里尔·迪德曼的同辈压力。他们各自作无罪抗辩，并在等待审判期间以10万美元的无担保保释金获释。然而几个月后，这四人都将抗辩改为认罪。在宣判前，莎拉·格雷夫斯的母亲玛丽（Mary）写信给法庭请求宽大处理，称她没有把女儿养大成种族主义者。玛丽不知道的是，莎拉已经写信给法庭说她的种族主义观点是在童年时期形成的，因为她的母亲经常在家里使用充满仇恨的种族主义语言。
Mary was questioned in court about the content of her daughter's letter, but she remained in denial, insisting she raised her children right. Judge Henry Wingate said that Graves couldn't make the excuse that she was in the wrong place at the wrong time, because she was in the place she wanted to be, being the person she wanted to be, but just didn't want to get caught. Craig's sister, Barbara, addressed the Graves and Richards, saying, You sat, watched, encouraged, and rallied around as my brother was beaten. Your thirst for the blood of an innocent African American caused you to pour more fuel on the fire. Craig's husband, James, who had mostly stayed silent during the court proceedings, told the young women, You texted everyone that night, but you couldn't call 911. You were as much to blame as if you'd been behind the wheel. Your baby's yourselves, but I don't feel sorry for you. You knew what you were doing. Shelby Richards was sentenced to eight years, and Sarah Graves would serve five.
玛丽在法庭上被问及她女儿信件的内容，但她仍然在否认，坚持说她把孩子养得很好。亨利·温盖特（Henry Wingate）法官说，格雷夫斯不能借口说自己在错误的时间出现在错误的地点，因为她就在她想去的地方，做着她想成为的人，只是不想被抓到。克雷格的妹妹芭芭拉对格雷夫斯和理查兹说：“当我的兄弟被殴打时，你们坐在那里、看着、鼓励着并围拢在一起。你们对无辜非裔美国人鲜血的渴望导致你们火上浇油。”克雷格的丈夫詹姆斯在法庭诉讼期间大多保持沉默，他告诉这些年轻女性：“那天晚上你们给所有人都发了短信，但你们却不能打911。你们和坐在方向盘后面的人一样负有责任。你们在自怜，但我一点也不替你们感到难过。你们知道自己在做什么。”谢尔比·理查兹被判处八年监禁，莎拉·格雷夫斯将服刑五年。
Speaking outside of court, Graves' mother, Mary, said she believed that presiding judge Henry Wingate was racist and should be taken off the bench. Graves' attorney agreed, saying, I was dealing with a black judge who was showing racial hatred towards white defendants. He was being a racist. Everybody's racist. I'm convinced of that. Sometimes they know it. Sometimes they don't know it. In response, Judge Wingate commented to The New York Times, quote, This notion of reverse discrimination is one that has plagued racial progress. The term usually signifies apathy for the rights bestowed upon African Americans, rights already enjoyed by most whites. During John Blalack's sentencing hearing, Pastor Brian Richardson testified on his behalf, telling the court that Blalack lacked a great deal of self-esteem and wanted to fit in. Pastor Richardson claimed that Blalack had been bullied by the group and had only joined them in order to survive, adding that at least three teens had taken their own lives after being bullied by the group. Blalack read a statement directed at Craig Anderson's family, saying that he wanted to make amends in any way he could and asked for their forgiveness.
格雷夫斯的母亲玛丽在法庭外发言时表示，她认为主审法官亨利·温盖特是种族主义者，应该被撤职。格雷夫斯的律师表示赞同，他说：“我在和一个对白人被告表现出种族仇恨的黑人法官打交道。他是个种族主义者。所有人都是种族主义者。对此我深信不疑。有时他们自己知道。有时他们自己不知道。”作为回应，温盖特法官对《纽约时报》评论道，引用原话：“这种反向歧视的概念一直是困扰种族进步的问题。这个术语通常表示对赋予非裔美国人权利的冷漠，而这些权利已经是大多数白人所享有的。”在约翰·布拉拉克的宣判听证会上，布赖恩·理查森（Brian Richardson）牧师为他出庭作证，告诉法庭布拉拉克缺乏大量的自尊心，并且想要融入群体。理查森牧师声称布拉拉克曾遭到该团伙的欺负，加入他们只是为了生存，并补充说至少有三名青少年在遭到该团伙欺负后自杀。布拉拉克宣读了一份针对克雷格·安德森家人的声明，称他希望以任何可能的方式进行弥补并请求他们的原谅。
Judge Wingate wasn't convinced that Blalack had shown any real remorse and fully expected that he'd align himself with racist groups once in prison. He urged Blalack to prove his sincerity by rebuilding his character before sentencing him to 20 years. Eight days later, Robert Rice, who was not present on the night Craig was murdered but had participated in the other attacks, was sentenced to 10 years. In addition to the wrongful death suit filed by Craig's family, the Civil Rights Division of the Justice Department prosecuted a restitution case against the Seven Defendants. The four most prominent members of the group, Daryl Deadman, John Rice, John Butler and William Montgomery, were ordered to pay a collective amount of $840,000 in restitution to Craig's estate. The amount was based on an estimate of Craig's lost future earnings and was intended to ease the financial burden on his family. The outcome of the family's civil lawsuit is unknown. On June 30, 2015, on what would have been Craig's 52nd birthday, Jackson City Council passed a hate crimes ordinance requiring training and adequate resources to help local law enforcement accurately report and document hate crimes committed in the city.
温盖特法官并不相信布拉拉克表现出了任何真正的悔意，并完全预计他一旦入狱就会与种族主义团伙结盟。他敦促布拉拉克在被判处20年监禁之前通过重建品格来证明自己的真诚。八天后，罗伯特·赖斯被判处10年监禁，他虽然在克雷格遇害当晚不在现场，但参与了其他袭击。除了克雷格家人提起的过失致死诉讼外，司法部民事权利司还对七名被告提起了赔偿诉讼。该团伙中最突出的四名成员达里尔·迪德曼、约翰·赖斯、约翰·巴特勒和威廉·蒙哥马利被命令向克雷格的遗产共同支付84万美元的赔偿金。该金额是基于对克雷格未来损失收入的估计，旨在减轻他家人的经济负担。该家庭民事诉讼的结果尚不清楚。2015年6月30日，在克雷格本应迎来52岁生日的那天，杰克逊市议会通过了一项仇恨犯罪条例，要求提供培训和充足的资源，以帮助当地执法部门准确报告和记录在该市发生的仇恨犯罪。
The ordinance also required that an annual report be provided to the city council regarding the occurrence of hate crimes in Jackson. That year, Jackson's annual report stated there were 36 hate groups operating in Mississippi. The Metro Inn was in an area of Jackson troubled by drug use and sex work, and there was speculation that the motel may have played a role in Craig's attack. Metro Inn's owner, Val Patel, said that the media had unfairly characterized his business. He told the Jackson Free Press that his motel provided a service to low-income families who had trouble finding affordable housing in the area. The Metro Inn was the first business coming off the Interstate 20, the highway used by Daryl Deadman and William Montgomery to drive from Brandon to Jackson. The district attorney of Jackson theorized that Craig would have been the first vulnerable black person that Deadman and his group came across. It was purely an opportunistic attack, and had Craig been elsewhere, the group would have targeted someone else.
该条例还要求每年向市议会提供关于杰克逊仇恨犯罪发生情况的报告。那一年，杰克逊的年度报告称，密西西比州有36个仇恨团体在活动。大都会客栈（Metro Inn）位于杰克逊一个饱受毒品和性工作困扰的地区，有猜测称该汽车旅馆可能在克雷格的袭击中发挥了一定作用。大都会客栈的老板瓦尔·帕特尔（Val Patel）表示，媒体对他的业务进行了不公正的描绘。他告诉《杰克逊自由报》（Jackson Free Press），他的汽车旅馆为在当地难以找到负担得起住房的低收入家庭提供服务。大都会客栈是下20号州际公路后的第一家企业，达里尔·迪德曼和威廉·蒙哥马利就是走这条高速公路从布兰登开车到杰克逊的。杰克逊的地区检察官推测，克雷格会是迪德曼及其团伙遇到的第一个脆弱的黑人。这纯粹是一次机会主义的袭击，如果克雷格在其他地方，该团伙就会把目标对准别人。
Val Patel denied rumors that he had sold the CCTV footage of Craig's murder to CNN, but said that without it, there would have been no evidence that it was a racially motivated hate crime. I formally believe in the right cause, and there is not one penny that was involved, other than the money that has killed me from a business point of view. A local councilman called for the motel to be permanently closed, labelling it a public nuisance. Unable to recover from the negative publicity, the Metro Inn permanently closed in 2017. On June 30, 2020, on what would have been Craig's 57th birthday, Mississippi passed a law to remove the Confederate emblem from the state flag. It was the last state in the US to retain the Confederate emblem, a popular symbol amongst the white supremacists that represents the war to uphold slavery. A commission is developing a new flag design that includes the phrase, in God we trust, with Mississippi scheduled to vote on the new design in November 2020. Since his husband's murder, James has worked to break the deep-rooted bigotry that incited the crime by teaching their adoptive son not to judge people based on the color of their skin.
瓦尔·帕特尔否认了有关他将克雷格谋杀案的闭路电视录像卖给美国有线电视新闻网（CNN）的谣言，但表示如果没有它，就不会有证据证明这是一起具有种族动机的仇恨犯罪。“我正式相信正义的事业，除了从商业角度让我破产的钱之外，没有一分钱参与其中。”一名当地议员呼吁永久关闭该汽车旅馆，称其为公共滋扰。由于无法从负面宣传中恢复过来，大都会客栈于2017年永久关闭。2020年6月30日，在克雷格本应迎来57岁生日的那天，密西西比州通过了一项法律，从州旗上去除了邦联徽章。它是美国最后一个保留邦联徽章的州，邦联徽章是白人至上主义者中流行的一个象征，代表着维护奴隶制的战争。一个委员会正在设计一面新旗帜，其中包括“我们信仰上帝”的短语，密西西比州预定于2020年11月对新设计进行投票。自丈夫遇害以来，詹姆斯一直致力于通过教导他们的养子不要根据肤色来评判他人，来打破煽动这起犯罪的根深蒂固的盲目偏执。
Former victim of Daryl Deadman, Jordan Richardson, told the Jackson Free Press that he didn't want the actions of his former bully to bolster racial stereotypes and tensions in his community. Quote, The stereotype that anywhere you go in Jackson, you better be looking over your shoulder, and in Brandon, anywhere you go, you are going to find rednecks. The only way that can happen is through a response of love for one community to the other. Of those convicted for the Jackson race attacks, very few have spoken publicly about their crimes. John Rice was willing to provide a comment to BuzzFeed News for a price. Joseph Dominic told the publication, Right now in society we're in the most volatile times with racism, but I've changed. It's been a different experience in prison. Most of the black guys in here know what I'm in for, but they still love me.
达里尔·迪德曼的前受害者乔丹·理查森（Jordan Richardson）告诉《杰克逊自由报》，他不想让前霸凌者的行为助长其社区的种族刻板印象和紧张局势。引用原话：“那种刻板印象是，无论你在杰克逊的什么地方，你最好都在留意周围，而在布兰登，无论你去哪里，你都会遇到乡巴佬。唯一能做到这一点的方法是通过一个社区对另一个社区的爱之回应。”在因杰克逊种族袭击而被定罪的人中，极少有人公开谈论他们的罪行。约翰·赖斯愿意出价为BuzzFeed News提供评论。约瑟夫·多米尼克对该出版物说：“现在在社会中，我们处于种族主义最动荡的时期，但我已经改变了。在监狱里这是一次不同的经历。这里的绝大多数黑人小伙子都知道我因何入狱，但他们依然爱我。”
William Montgomery refused to take any personal responsibility for Craig Anderson's death and only felt sorry for himself. Quote, I lost my freedom, family, and everything else for a crime I didn't commit. As of July 2020, Dylan Butler, Joseph Dominic, Jonathan Gaskamp, and Sarah Graves have served their time and been released from prison, while the others remain behind bars. Daryl Deadman is the only one of the 10 people involved in the Jackson race attacks, who is never expected to be released. When sentencing Deadman in 2015, Judge Carton Reeves said, Hate comes in all shapes, sizes, colors, and from this case, we know it comes in different sexes and ages. A toxic mix of alcohol, foolishness, and unadulterated hatred caused these young people to resurrect the nightmarish specter of lynchings and lynch mobs from the Mississippi we long to forget. They prowled, they came ready to hurt, they used the dangerous weapons, they targeted the weak, they recruited and encouraged others to join in the coordinated chaos, and they boasted about their shameful activity.
威廉·蒙哥马利拒绝为克雷格·安德森的死承担任何个人责任，并且只觉得对不起自己。引用原话：“我为了一起我没有犯下的罪行失去了自由、家庭和一切。”截至2020年7月，迪伦·巴特勒、约瑟夫·多米尼克、乔纳森·加斯坎普和莎拉·格雷夫斯已经服刑期满并从监狱释放，而其他人则继续留在铁窗后。达里尔·迪德曼是参与杰克逊种族袭击的10人中唯一一个预计永远不会被释放的人。2015年在对迪德曼进行宣判时，卡尔顿·里夫斯法官说：“仇恨有各种形状、大小、颜色，从这个案子中我们知道它有不同的性别和年龄。酒精、愚蠢和纯粹仇恨的致命混合物导致这些年轻人复活了我们渴望忘记的密西西比州林奇私刑和暴民的噩梦般幽灵。他们四处搜寻，他们带着伤害的准备前来，他们使用了危险武器，他们以弱者为目标，他们招募并鼓励其他人加入到协调一致的混乱中，他们为他们那可耻的活动吹嘘。”
Like a lynching, for these young folk, going out to Africa was like a carnival outing. It was funny to them, an excursion which culminated in the death of innocent African-American James Craig Anderson. On June 26, 2011, the fun ended. What is so disturbing, so shocking, so numbing is that these hunts were perpetrated by our children, students who live among us, educated in our public schools, in our private academies, students who played football, lined up on the same side of the scrimmage line with black teammates, average students and honor students, kids who worked during school and in the summers, kids who now had full-time jobs and some of whom were even unemployed. Some were pursuing higher education, and the court believes they each had dreams to pursue. These children were from two parent homes, and some of whom were the children of divorced parents, and yes, some even raised by a single parent. No doubt, they all had loving parents and loving families. What could transform these young adults into the violent creatures their victims saw?
就像林奇私刑一样，对于这些年轻人来说，去非洲就像是一次狂欢节郊游。这对外他们来说很有趣，是一次以无辜非裔美国人詹姆斯·克雷格·安德森的死而告终的远足。2011年6月26日，快乐结束了。如此令人不安、如此令人震惊、如此令人麻木的是，这些狩猎是由我们的孩子实施的，他们是生活在我们中间的学生，在我们的公立学校、我们的私立学校受过教育，是那些踢足球、在混战线同一边与黑人队友并肩作战的学生，是普通学生和优秀学生，是那些在学校和夏天工作的孩子，是现在有全职工作甚至有些人失业的孩子。有些人正在追求高等教育，法院相信他们每个人都有要追求的梦想。这些孩子来自双亲家庭，其中一些是离异父母的孩子，是的，甚至有些人是由单亲抚养长大的。毫无疑问，他们都有慈爱的父母和充满爱的家庭。是什么能将这些年轻人变成他们的受害者所看到的暴力生物呢？
It was nothing the victims did. They were not championing any cause, political, social, economic. Nothing they did. Not a wolf whistle, not a supposed crime. Nothing they did. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这不是受害者做的任何事。他们没有捍卫任何事业，无论是政治的、社会的还是经济的。不是他们做的任何事。不是狼哨，不是所谓的犯罪。不是他们做的任何事。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。